[Musique]
salut c'est cheuvreux aujourd'hui de
vous parler de 500 hommes une fois n'est
pas coutume
samsung a beaucoup d'action en ce moment
on attend avec impatience l'arrivée du
galaxy note note qui va arriver ce qui
va arriver d'ici quelques jours
et là ils ont fait une annonce un petit
peu en catimini c'est une nouvelle
tablette pas forcément destiné qu'aux
particuliers mais également aux
professionnels un produit on peut avoir
une utilisation un petit peu hybride
ce modèle s'appelle la samsung galaxy
tab s4 elle vient prendre la suite de la
galaxy tab est roi et là je vous en
parle maintenant
s'il ya un marché qui est vraiment
d'eric et en ce moment c'est celui des
tablettes sur android beaucoup de
constructeurs qui sont tentés cette
année qui cette attaque la mégapanne n 5
et la mediapad n 5 pro que j'ai pu
prendre en main lorsque j'étais à
barcelone au mwc plutôt pas mal je
trouve assez brillant et c'est vrai que
règle générale le grand public ne serait
pas pour acheter des tablettes
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous vous avez acheté
une tablette android est ce que vous
pourriez on essaie de le faire est ce
que vous voyez l'utilité ou alors est-ce
qu'un smartphone ça vous suffit
smartphone ordinateur est ce qu'une
tablette milieu a vraiment sa place et
par marque et tout ça en commentaires
via microsoft aussi canon scié pas très
longtemps alors introduit un peu hybride
entre un pc portable une tablette c'est
la surface go on va avoir des sicap lui
tend alors effectivement et aussi tout
le côté professionnel avec la surface
pro que j'ai pu tester ou s'il n'ya pas
très longtemps c'est cette tablette mais
c'est vrai que les tablettes sous
android remporte pas forcément un franc
succès samsung a fait le choix de sortir
un produit plus destiné aux
professionnels plus destiné surtout à la
productivité
c'est une tablette haut de gamme avec un
design qui est légèrement amélioré par
rapport à son prédécesseur
un doux envers la disparition du bouton
home physique donc on déverrouille plus
avec un capteur d'empreintes digitales
c'est la reconnaissance à l'iris ou
alors le chesnois ou alors encore votre
petit code on a un écran super amoled de
10,5 pouces avec une définition de 2560
par 1600 pixels un ratio 16 10ème une
résolution de 287 p pays et un écran qui
occupent 79% de la face avant
côté puissance pour les états unis on a
un processeur qualcomm snapdragon 835
alors pour l'europe on a un exynos de
samsung 8 1895 c'est celui qu'on peut
retrouver dans le samsung et suit tout
cela couplé à 4 gigas de ram et il est
dispo soit 64 giga de stockage soit en
256 go de stockage et tout 506 avec une
carte microsd jusqu'à 400 giga il a une
grosse batterie comme ça vous allez
vraiment avoir le temps de voir venir
7300 millions terreur et en plus de ça
il recharge rapide sur une batterie de
7300 diop erreur ce n'est pas une charge
rapide vous avez pour la laisser
brancher un certain temps avant qu'elle
fasse du prime donc en tout cas vous
êtes tranquille le son devrait être pas
mal du tout avec quatre haut parleurs
positionner aux quatre coins de
l'appareil quatre haut parleurs à kg ce
qui supporte le
me atmos sur land un son vraiment
faciale ise quelque chose dit merci ça
peut être super bien ce que vous allez
regarder des vidéos lorsque vous allez
jouer vous allez vraiment la sensation
inertie il s'appelle vraiment cool tant
que samsung nous annonce l'adaptation
sonore en fonction de la position de
votre tablette
donc ça devrait être vraiment
intéressant côté photo vous avez un 13
mégapixels à l'arrière avec un autofocus
à l'avant c'est un 8 mégapixels qui vous
servira pour la reconnaissance de l'iris
pour dérouiller on absolument aucune
info actuellement sur l'ouverture des
appareils toute façon c'est très
clairement une tablette qui fait pour
faire des photos de haute qualité de
haute précision faible luminosité qu'on
pourrait la voir sur en est la phase la
plus sûre des photophones on n'est pas
là dessus vous pouvez filmer en 4k uhd à
30 images par seconde
vouloir charger en usd type c à la du
bluetooth 5.0 vous avez le style et le
fpn de samsung qui est inclue dedans et
elle tourne sous android
8.1 oreo un point qui était mis en avant
qui est vraiment intéressant pour le
côté productivité
c'est le decs le dext est toujours revus
et améliorés par samsung
vous n'avez pas besoin d'acheter quelque
chose en plus fournir le positionner
supa de daix que vous allez transporté
avec vous le decs vous allez la voir
il nous faut juste un petit adaptateur
usb type c hdmi fournir le brancher à un
moniteur et là il va se transformer et
il va devenir un petit ordinateur
portable vous avez aussi un clavier qui
le cover vous pouvez acheter en
supplément qui vous permettra vraiment
l'utiliser comme un ordinateur vous avez
donc votre tablette hop le clavier une
souris bluetooth et si vous branchez
tous à un moniteur vous fait un seul
grand écran avec une interface android
d'aix vous allez pouvoir générer du
multitâche ça ça peut être vraiment
intéressant c'est un produit qui vous
permettra de faire de la prise de notes
de faire des croquis des dessins de
travailler comme je le dis pour la
productivité avec le decs dans l'année
les films écouter de la musique
bon ça c'est un grand basique bien
évidemment les réseaux sociaux les email
et lorsque vous posez sur le soc
il aura un mode veille pour faire
défiler des photos pour la météo pour
avoir goûté un petit peu pratique un peu
sympa il va être très bientôt dispo en
pré commande et vous allez pouvoir le
recevoir à partir du 24 août prochain au
tarif de 699 euros pour le mode wifi et
759 euros pour la version 4g et si vous
les camions plus il vous coûtera 149
euros à voir si samsung va réussir à
trouver sa clientèle sur ce segment je
sais pas vous
vous intéresser est ce que vous seriez
prêt à acheter une tablette pour la voir
comme un petit ordinateur
est ce que vous pensez qu'une tablette
dans ce type de configuration pourrait
remplacer un ordinateur de bureau pour
du traitement de texte basique un pas
pour aller faire du montage ou de l'a32
des choses qui vont nécessiter plus de
puissance mais est ce que vous pensez
qu'une tablette comme la galaxy tab s4
pourrez vous intéressez-vous marque est
aussi un commentaire comme d'hab je
lutte à rester connectés parce que d'ici
quelques jours on va parler d'une autre
9 ailleurs plein plein de plein de
choses à dire qu'il ya plein de
surprises quelque chose qui arrive donc
on va se connecter vous invite à laisser
des jolies pousse à demain soyez sages
et je vous embrasse tous
[Musique]